[Music]
meagan Markel is resuming her royal
duties for months after giving birth to
her favorite son Archie the Duchess of
Sussex launched her much-anticipated
charity clothing line yesterday in
London it will help women find job
appropriate attire and employment
opportunities Roxana Saberi shows us
Megan's ideas for dressing for success
hi everyone
pairing our love of fashion with her
passion for empowering women as women it
is a hundred percent our responsibility
I think to support and uplift each other
the Dutchess of Sussex revealed a
charity clothing collection five items
ranging from around 30 to 250 dollars
for every item sold an identical one
will be donated to smart works such as
hand-me-downs
British charity giving unemployed women
training and clothing to boost their
confidence as a royal patron Megan
visited many times helping women like
Dionne Johnson prepare for a job
interview I went for a dressing session
and she was there she got stuck right in
like what they said you know rolled up
her sleeves she was still heavily
pregnant at the time and she picked out
a couple of bits for me and it was
really nice for her to say you know how
good it looked and you know empowering
Dionne got the job but the Duchess said
the closet wasn't fit for everyone so
she helped design these basic pieces in
the past the Megan effect has
skyrocketed sales of her clothing and
this collection is on the same track CBS
this morning
Roxana Saberi London that's great she
has a great sense of style so as she
said when you wear something when she
wears something people I want that too
it takes off